[Música]
Hola soy María Clara calle y les doy la
bienvenida a un nuevo episodio de La
Crónica de medio ambiente
el área metropolitana de Montevideo
donde vive el 60% de la población de
Uruguay podría quedarse sin agua a
finales de junio según las autoridades
la razón es que el suministro está muy
escaso y están combinando el agua dulce
del río Santa Lucía con la salada
proveniente del río de la plata el
resultado se siente en el gusto con un
agua más salada y que en efecto Lleva
más odio de hecho la empresa Estatal
obra sanitarias del estado oce y el
Ministerio de salud pública elevaron los
topes máximos de 200 a 440 miligramos de
sodio por litro de agua y también
incrementaron el cloro para subir la
desinfección el gobierno reconoce que
aunque no es potable en su definición
explícita
si es bebible
se va a dar con la seguridad de que la
población general puede tomar esta agua
a pesar de que sus este sus
características de olor y de sabor sean
salobres y tal vez no sean tan
agradables para la población la
población en general los puede tomar con
total seguridad la recomendación que se
hace Es que aquellos pacientes que
tengan hipertensión arterial sobre todo
severa que tengan que hacer dietas muy
estrictas en cuanto a su consumo de
sodio tengan un control más frecuente de
las cifras de presión arterial Y si ven
que hay una alteración en esas cifras Un
aumento de esas cifras de presión
arterial que consulten a un médico y
bueno dentro de la medida de lo posible
tal vez puedan tomar agua que sea este
agua embotellada los niveles de sodio y
cloro lo subieron a principios de mayo y
ahora extendieron la medida hasta el 20
de julio Pero por qué está tan escasa el
agua en Montevideo la principal razón es
la sequía que comenzó hace tres años
esto ha hecho que La Represa pasó
Severino que nutre al área metropolitana
este de niveles históricamente bajos al
7 de junio tenía solo 4,4 millones de
metros cúbicos de agua de los 67
millones que puede albergar lo
paradójico es que Uruguay está sobre una
de las mayores reservas de aguas
subterráneas del mundo el acuífero
guaraní que comparte con Argentina
Brasil y Paraguay El problema es que
este llega solo al norte del país Por
otra parte las cuencas de los ríos
Uruguay y negro y del Lago merín y el
Océano Atlántico no alcanzan a
Montevideo el suministro de la capital
es del río Santa Lucía que es el que
nutre de La Represa paso Severino y que
es el que se está secando de allí que
para el área metropolitana que en este
mapa lo ven en color rojo hayan tenido
que combinar el agua dulce del Santa
Lucía con la del río de la plata
y como no ha llovido en las últimas
semanas los niveles siguen siendo bajos
además de la larga sequía Ernesto
Fernández director de la oficina
regional UNESCO Montevideo que atiende a
Argentina Uruguay y Paraguay considera
que otra de las razones es la cultura de
creer que el agua es inagotable de hecho
en la ciudad vieja de la capital
uruguaya hay una tradición de despedir
el año viejo lanzando el suministro
hídrico por esto Fernández promueve un
cambio de chip
empieza por que en Uruguay desde
pequeños pequeñas el mensaje es tenemos
mucha agua el agua sobra casi el agua va
a ser nuestra riqueza del futuro pero
claro el agua como tantas otras riquezas
no está distribuido uniformemente y en
Montevideo en este momento con la sequía
con estos tres años de sequía
que yo creo se puede atribuir claramente
a las situaciones del del cambio
climático hoy por hoy
se llegó un momento de la sequía en la
que la Cuenca del río Santa Lucía no
probé agua suficiente para
el la ciudad el núcleo urbano de la
ciudad de Montevideo
y es esa la fuente de agua potable la
pregunta del millón es cuál es la
solución y la osce estaba aplicando
varias a la vez por un lado están
explotando aguas subterráneas y como una
medida paliativa a corto plazo están
distribu en carros cisterna agua sin
salinizar para los hospitales y las
escuelas a más largo plazo se tiene
pensado la construcción de una nueva
Represa en parador trajes para que
recolecte aguas de los ríos San José y
de la plata para llevarlas a la capital
y también en el estado uruguayo está
comprando una aplicación móvil para que
las personas puedan tener crédito en sus
celulares y comprar agua embotellada
Aunque la UNESCO insiste en que lo
principal es cuidar el agua esto no debe
volver a pasar y que para eso se
requiere pensar repensar la forma en la
que se gestiona el agua y sobre todo
cambiar la cultura esta cultura de que
hablábamos antes de que el agua está
sobra está omnipresente bueno no el agua
debe ser conservada el agua de ser
tratada el agua con respeto ya desde
fines del año pasado no se puede ni
lavar autos ni regar y creo que la la
sociedad en general como lo ha tomado lo
ha tomado muy bien Bueno al tomarlo
aceptado y
ahora el problema es que más no que más
se puede cortar la verdad es que es una
situación muy crítica y sobre todo que
si no pensamos bien la si no se mira
desde el punto de vista estructural
puede volver a ocurrir tarde o temprano
este año va a llover viene el invierno o
sea viene viene las lluvias pero el año
que viene vuelve a haber un verano es
decir no no podemos pensar en en que
todo dependa de cuando vuelve a llover
sino de cambiar realmente más
estructuralmente y así llegamos al final
de La Crónica de medio ambiente pueden
ver este y todos los capítulos en France
24.com nos vemos en una próxima ocasión
[Música]